[Music]
hey guys Dimitri from the score eSports
look we cannot wait for the 2019 Berlin
major so in anticipation
we've decided to count down the top 10
aces ever to happen at a major we're
talking aces and gun rounds aces and
pistol rounds and of course the coveted
ace clutch both top mid and all the way
over toward atrium taps it goes quite
cold zeros quicker gets a second as well
as the ball will go down and follows it
up through all lining up cool fare with
an ace but beautiful one as well so
leave those weak-ass double kills and
triple kills at home because this week
we're only accepting the full 5 let's
get on with the list kicking off our
list is a sweet 1v5 ace clutch at the e
league Atlanta major 2017 courtesy of
JDM down 15 to 9 team liquids T side
offense was shut down by team envyus on
cash leaving JDM in a dire 1v5 situation
fortunately for liquid
JDM didn't see it that way forward to
try and find them get them both in his
sights manages only one JD I'm looking
that correct direction but it's a 1
versus 4 AWP [ __ ] shout good shot JD
after another he's got this down to one
versus two over a commitment and perhaps
a little bit zealous to try it early end
this the a squatch and we stay alive an
ace is often accented by the final round
securing kill but in the case of ex
curates 200 IQ ace from the 2018 face at
London major it begins before he even
fires a shot X can angle towards
infernos arch and perfectly body blocked
gambit gaming smoke which served as the
beginning to a jaw-dropping ace a gap
nothing to what absolute wonders sports
a second player coming out to boiler as
well we can alert his teammates and they
could keep a focus on the a sights
it's very difficult out to move into
this angle for a dren you know he knows
that and offers posted up and does he
asked for a flashing and time assigned
to run led there is no flash they just
bought peek into these angles how do
they how do you manage this there is not
really a good solution here for gambit
general it used to smoke though and push
for is it just try to make something
happen if you can somehow take out one
player before hit the main push comes in
and just destabilize the defense in that
way they can do this is it gonna trade
fast enough no no he isn't
oh that's disgusting that is absolutely
disgusting to make secure another
headshot to finish off the job yeah it's
nice it's not Wow cheeky a spare from
execute the precision that he is capable
of is is something to marvel at just
head shots all the rounds making its way
in at number eight is else's baptism by
fire from the 2019 Katowice major now
this tournament may have been the
American players first ever major but he
didn't let it show despite being tested
early in the first round of his first
match the rookie found himself in a
daunting one before
second one automatic goes down and it's
the lucky everything to do and he's
delivering a war on two and grant slows
down the retake truly is a baptism of
fire vis elseis already picked up three
sterling and Malta remain and he's
spidey senses are tingling he's gonna
pick up another headshot consensus
feasibly pull this one off
it's all down to Sterling whittling away
the time what a kick but it doesn't
matter South is with a beautiful coach
and cloud line will pick up the first
round welcome to the majors young man
five kills an ace and a pistol round and
bails quad Knight out of a hole that is
a beautiful round coming in at number
seven is Olaf Meister's legendary tech 9
ace against Navi from the Katowice 2015
major the tech 9 has seen better days in
the competitive meta but when you see
what could be done in the hands of
counter-strike royalty
it's not hard to see why it was
eventually nerfed into the grass
with all of my static line and armor
it's really really good combination but
unless they fight in one of the time oh
my god are they will pronax helping out
with that kill and Guardian going down
and it's now a triple kill fall off my
he's got plenty of help to do this as
well Suz is very low seized
although oh my god he gets another
killing now clocks running out seven
seconds olofmeister looking for the kill
fight it goes for it and it's gonna be
the round done and fnatic steal it all
off Meister steals it coming in at
number six is Tarek's silky-smooth ace
from the Boston major now this play not
only took place during the majors grand
final
but happened in overtime against a
heavily favored faze clan how about that
for some na pride discovered tag will
take him down into five before the
carbine with 40 seconds to go and
Kerrigan
he can't reposition he has the frag he
asked a frag and he gets only one and
now that's cloud but I'm moving quickly
towards P they have the utility but all
the flights are on the flank can he
catch brush it brush pops up and rushes
lockdown whack-a-mole therefore all of
my stupid Guardian still in position
they managed to get there fast enough
the bomb has to be pointed in card line
at a disadvantage
Taric brave enough to just hold the
bombs gone he knows God is in
construction trying to back off fight to
reposition season tides in but doesn't
drag him holding the angle once again
but as they go hide as you go low
it is a dance and now they concede
multiple angles Carrico he takes on a
five-star down
Guardian on 11 HP reigns at peeks and he
gets the angle now superior angle is
there a diffuse for the CT side the nor
ninjas yet they're spamming the grenades
they're touching the pod and now go
frame another poblet is
no God has taken down absolutely unreal
right cloud9 Tarek is the God all
semantics was essentially his cameraman
in that position waiting for the moment
to actually trade but Terry didn't even
need the assist what's better than one
ace
well how about - which is why flame EES
historic back-to-back aces from earlier
this year comes in at number five on our
list during the 2019 Katowice major faze
clan forced not to spence-air into a
retake position on infernos b site but
flamey wasn't fazed by his team's poor
position that may not be true when the
guns are brought out but for now it
certainly is the first kill though go is
the way a flaming he already has the
pistol it's just enough to cut off one
on the retake but the bomb already
planted for Navi and they just have to
hold it off that's not hard flame he's
got another it's gonna be extremely
difficult if simple can get around from
coffins without being spotted new box is
preoccupied if he wraps in they're both
gone for neo and they're gonna push it
all together great can't do it up just
to Nico third of the world last year but
he's got a two on one on one poems
cheapness got a sling they know that
flamey what a pistol an ace he gets an
ace welcome to spa tech everybody and
the longtime Navi player didn't lose any
momentum heading into the second pistol
round as he brazenly pushed through
smokes to take the B site and phases
hope at winning the round a man who got
an ace last time he's got two with you
the only two for Navi so far flaming as
the ball gets planted inside of B Olaf's
gonna take the long rotation into flight
from behind Zeus is watching it it's
Guardian that wants rain
to work with him so we can get in from
Rouen so we can take somebody attention
away to skip up to study clear banana
ain't hat dolak was in behind the wall
they're gonna think that's wide open but
now they realize with the other kills
they've all turned around flame he's
looking for double ace in the pistol
double ace in the pretzel both of them
ten kills two pistols to rout for Navi
with that the Russian superstar achieved
aces in both pistol rounds of a single
map the first time that's ever happened
at a major coldzera Zhou face from the
2017 Atlanta major is likely the fastest
ace on this list which is just one of
the reasons why it makes its way in at
number four big tried their best to pick
off an isolated cold Zahra on infernos
arch by rushing him but they only ran
single-file to their death well and he's
elated for good reason
My gods beautiful beautiful stuff didn't
miss a beat that's so rad five dogs and
five girls man
twenty that range as well how sick is
that look at the eyes he's calling us
yeah absolutely
taking the number three spot on our list
is Freiburg filthy ace from the 2014
cologne major that reminds us why the
Swedish legend is the king of banana
cs:go Swedish Derby is the stuff of
legends and it comes as no surprise that
a match between those two teams could
produce a play of this caliber thrown by
an F to try and hold them back all of
Meister will find the shot on the exist
primer does return picks on pronax he's
still here though and he's going for
more - big frags that third man is here
our friend Freiburg has to back off both
pride
single-handedly all three frags but the
phone is on the other side yeah but that
could be alright if an icicle making a
huge rotation Fryeburg all yes to just
stay alive it is gonna be great
Paul he picks up a quad kill he could do
even better than staying alive he gets
the kill now is it gonna be an ace with
five HP that's what's on the plate right
now for Freiburg JW on the other hand
has quite a different menu to chew
through here he's got a one on three
with an AWP guess the right bomb site
but the bomb goes down so now he not
only has to kill three members of an IP
also has to defuse the bomb and I'm
wondering if it isn't smarter at this
but try and find a way out but from the
depths like a hungry shark just inching
his way forward here he wants that ace
and that would be absolutely beautiful
fancy that could read he walked in
Fryeburg comes in he sprays
[Applause]
we've seen some big brain plays on this
list but nafs 1v2 ace against ends from
the 2019 Katowice major is one for the
history books which is why it takes the
runner-up spot on our list in fact if
there was a csgo handbook this play
would be exhibit a on how to take B site
on Mirage
don't believe us just take a look for
yourself the boo stuff oh honey find
that he plays down on the bench Jesse
can Alexei be caught napping we're gonna
bullet perforating through his heads now
this does give liquid a chance did you
have control the bomber that is found
himself to kill on x7 we've got a round
of it now ladies and gentlemen the bombs
we get planted and ends not to try and
retake enough gonna take the risk of
going into apps he has struck once again
he's gonna have to come up with a wall
onto clutch polish and a see if he's
gonna pull this out the Hat it's
breathing down his neck smoking to get
deployed onto the psychotron skew
duration Oh
flick off the Sergei that is another fly
gonna use that smoke to advantage just
pause back to the van waiting
anticipating an ally push
absolutely sensational
Naf played his angles perfectly and even
use ences own utility against them
forcing a loo into a risky play taking
the top spot on our list is a major ace
that is nearly four years old but proves
that oldies are still goodies that's
right we're talking about rains
monstrous 1v5 ace clutch from the 2015
cluj-napoca major left in a 1v5 against
team envyus
with very little information to go on
rain proceeded to pick the French squad
apart it's just rain left alive he's
gonna find the quick kill on to happy
but he's got Kirishima to contend with
what a frag they're coming in from rain
to try to get the frag onto the Viking
play the game sense from this man he's
not real there's still two more players
to find though rain he's gonna get
another one
fbk goes down he's created a 101 he's
got so much time to use this well he's
gonna make his way back back towards the
middle position he's gonna try to trick
his opponent right now apex so oh my
goodness gracious me rain is an absolute
monster there's a reason why this play
range supreme as the single greatest ace
in major history now if you're as big as
csgo fan as we are you're probably
hoping that this list is gonna need some
updating by the time the Berlin major
comes to a close until then like the
video subscribe to our channel and be
sure to let us know in the comments what
other high pass csgo stuff you want us
to list see you next time thanks for
watching if you want more content like
this hit the sub button and ring that
notification bell for unique bite-sized
videos you won't find anywhere else
hit up our Instagram Twitter and
Facebook pages